our series a more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as americans is
far greater than what divides us
many of us are discovering that it can
take a superhuman effort to find an
available dose of the covid vaccine
in one pennsylvania community a
pharmacist known as
dr mack and his superpower is helping
saving lives cbs news correspondent
nancy chen explains
dr mack is responsible for these shots
this is the superman
he's known as dr mack and his superman
costume is a halloween leftover
but for the people at this pop-up
vaccine clinic my uncle mean
is the real deal we'll be back so let
your neighbors know awesome
we appreciate you bringing it to us the
pharmacist is vaccinating everyone he
can
in this community 45 minutes outside of
philadelphia
reaching more than 3 500 people in a day
cover 19 vaccines have been so tough to
get and when that ups driver walked
through that door
and said here are your vaccines we were
almost dancing like getting ready to
party because this is what our town has
been waiting for
and now you're delivering your vaccines
as superman
i continue to wear the superman costume
because of the responses that i've seen
from the community
it doesn't require a child to see
supermac to get some happiness or joy
the center of his operation this small
independent pharmacy
until recently the only one in the town
of skipac
offering vaccines we have one full-time
employee
and myself two people to be able to
administer 4 000 vaccines
on top of that running a pharmacy is not
something that's possible
but having an army of volunteers behind
you they're doing it because they love
every single person in this community
and because this is a community effort
you're getting an email within the next
24 to 48 hours to be
looking for that 400 people have signed
up to man the phones and coordinate
appointments
with just 24 to 36 hours notice
once the vaccines come into our pharmacy
and get put into the freezer
then it's time to move into action we
have to call
and or email a thousand people to let
them know that the vaccines arrived this
clinic was organized by his team at a
community center in nearby norristown
one of the county's hardest hit areas
denise ash
is the center's ceo you see people one
day in the next day
they have kovic they're getting sick and
a lot of people we know
have lost relatives you ready i'm ready
tanya hall says she likely would have
had to wait until may to get a vaccine
because of her limited mobility i live
right up the street
you know it's really great to have
something like this
close to home thank you guys for being
patient today from large
clinics vaccinating hundreds by the hour
to visits at home one at a time
they pay you good money to put that
outfit on
nine-year-old joseph dildine and his
wife marsha that's it
you are fully vaccinated yay now closer
to seeing their grandchildren without
worry
we're all huggers six feet apart and it
just doesn't work it's just not the same
it's a nice idea but you know you can't
hug them and we miss that a lot
the effort is paying off the county now
has one of the highest per capita
vaccination rates in the state
a mission to help others in line with
his faith
my guru and you see the the red dot with
the the you here
that's a symbol of my faith his motto is
in the joy of others
lies our own so anything that we do if
you're bringing somebody else joy
just do it how do you think the
community will remember this i think our
community
absolutely loves the fact that their
local superheroes
banded together to do something that no
one ever thought was possible
for cbs this morning nancy chen skip
back pennsylvania
it is a heroic effort dr mack says he's
helped give out 22 thousand vaccine
doses
since early february